Congratulations on making it to lesson six. This
is the final lesson for the course, and we
brought in Facebook data scientist Saung Masin to share
with you some of his own work in EDA.
>> In this lesson, I'll walk you through an analysis of
diamonds. You'll learn about the rich history behind the diamond market, and
use the EDA techniques that you've
learned to develop a quantitative understanding
of it. The ultimate goal is to build a predictive model of
diamonds that's going to help you figure out whether a
given diamond is a good deal, or a rip-off.
>> If you're in the market for a diamond, exploring this
data set can help you understand what goes into the price
of a diamond, and even if you're not looking to buy,
the socioeconomic and political history of the diamond industry is fascinating.
>> Diamonds gave rise to the mining industry in
South Africa, which is now the most advanced economy in
the region. Diamonds also drove the British and
the Dutch to colonize southern Africa in the first
place, and have driven conflicts ranging from the Boer
wars to modern day civil strife across the region.
>> Now, you should have some experience
working with the diamonds data based on
the problem sets in this course. I'll
let Solomon guide you through his exploration.